Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen. My name is Steve
uh Van Wyk or Van Wyk, whichever rolls
off the tongue easier.
Um, I currently head up the
global team at SAP
which looks after technology and innovation
within the S4 business, um, so the
RS Organization,
and we help our customers move from an on-premise world
into cloud.
Today, we're gonna talk a little around um the
need for change within businesses. Um,
we're gonna give you a little bit of insight into what we're seeing
with our customers, the ones that are moving from an on-premise
world to rise, uh,
because this is a little distance, so I don't need those
anymore. Um, we'll talk a little
around the North Star for SAP. So what is the strategy,
um, from an SAP perspective around cloud,
uh, a bit around the customer journey, uh, uh,
the rise with SAP methodology. So the
customers that are
moving from an on-premise world into the cloud space,
um, what that looks like.
Uh, we will touch a little bit on the cleaner
core environment,
uh, and why it's so important when you're looking
in the cloud scenarios.
Um, we'll, we'll touch on the integrated tool chain,
which is some of the tool set which will help you accelerate
the cloud.
And finally, right at the end, we'll bring it all together, so
hopefully, it makes a little bit of sense.
OK. So, uh, some of the customers in terms
of, uh, conversations that we've been having,
uh, I love this analogy. Uh,
it's, uh, in the early 1900s, effectively,
this is New York City. Um,
and basically, it's Fifth Avenue. And if you look
on the left-hand side, it was a horse-driven
cart environment in, in the early 1900s.
And, uh, just 13 years later,
you can see the picture on the right-hand side around automobiles.
And I mean, the history of man is
one of innovation, right? So we've innovated
since the beginning of time and we continue to
do so today.
And technology is the accelerator and the enabler
that does that today.
Um a little around SAP. Uh
we've been around 53 years, which is exactly
how old I am, so it makes me feel pretty
good. Um, the company started
back in uh the early 70s when, with
the release of R1,
which was um effectively a transaction
processing system that literally looked at
a business process
and mapped it back into a, a computer
system. Uh we released R2
in the 80s and that really was
what we call the real-time uh computing
system. Uh, effectively, we put into a
GL structure.
And there was no day-end processing into the GL
or month-end processing, so we called it a real-time
platform. Uh, in the 90s,
we released um server
or released uh server 3,
which essentially was a client-server architecture.
So for customers who were operating on
a global uh entity that were looking at
multi-language environments, that were looking at multi-day
end, month-end closes,
uh, year-end closes, etc. So different,
um, different time zones of
operation, right? Um,
and then we brought out in the early 2003,
somewhere around there, we brought out something called the SAP
Business Suite.
And you'll recognize that name because that's where we are
today with the SAP business suite based in cloud.
And that's where we decoupled some of the lines of business,
HR, SRM, supply, uh, uh,
uh, CRM for example,
from the core set of financials and customers had the choice
to roll out the financials and then at a later stage,
either deploy alternative solutions around
line of business or alternatively,
uh, just couple on the, uh, the lines of business,
right? And then we brought out in 2010,
we brought out something called in-memory computing. We invented
an in-memory database called HANA,
which allowed you to insert a, a transaction
and then run queries against the transaction
milliseconds later.
It changed the way that uh customers were
consuming information. There was no latency of data
anymore, and we called it a real-time operating
platform.
And in the early 2010s, we started looking
into things like predictive algorithms and we acquired
companies along the way like KXEN.
Which essentially allowed us to take
uh a business process, look at the business
process and splice in some predictive algorithms
into the process so that you would end up at a different
state depending on who was interacting
with the actual business process itself.
That morphed into something called machine learning
and automated um deliverables
where literally what you could do is you could look at some of
the business processes and figure out
how to reduce the human interaction with the business
process. And we brought out something called the intelligent
enterprise, which literally had machine learning
built into it.
And that in itself morphed into where we are
today, which is + 2022, 2023.
We have
uh a cloud ERP and the cloud, of
course, and we have artificial intelligence, which is
actually built into the application layer
itself. Um,
If you look at all these disruptions that we launched to market,
so R1, R2, R3, we certainly
disrupted the way that the industry was,
was operating and, and we led the way in, in
terms of enterprise resource planning.
As it is today with artificial intelligence, I
personally think it's the greatest invention that
humankind has created in its whole
history, and I do believe it's not only changing
the way that we're operating today, but will change the
way for
the way we're gonna do business for decades to come. And
certainly the aggregate of all these disruptions
over time doesn't come close
to where we are today with the cloud version of, of the
solution area.
Some of the global disruptions that are happening in the
industry, and they happen by themselves. They,
they're actually independent of your organization and
your company, right?
But if you look at the geopolitical tensions that are
going on in the world, tariff wars that are, are
on, we've got wars that are happening in the Ukraine.
It changes the way migration patterns work, consumption
patterns work,
supply chains work. Um, pretty
much the backdrop of
how we're operating today is to talk about it
and say, well, the acceleration of change
is the norm in the industry today.
And certainly in the markets that we're operating in.
And as a result, one has to start thinking about,
well, how do I think about model expansion?
How do I think about shaving out costs within my business?
How do I look at taking advantage of opportunities
in the market
through either through mergers and acquisitions? How do
I acquire more customers for my business, etc.
All of these things require us
to have a, a technology platform
that allows us to drive continuous innovation.
And the reality is technology is the enabler.
Um, so if you look at some of the external
studies.
Um, like McKinsey, for example. This
one's quite interesting.
Um, in the history of mankind, if,
if I think about the, the S&P 500 companies
over the last 20 years, since 2005
to 2025,
only 7 companies are present in
the same set of results.
OK. And if you look at it, it's quite an
interesting comparison, right?
Because actually, technology companies are the ones that
are accelerating um into the
top um uh 20
companies for the last 25 years.
Um, so if you think about organizations
like Kodak, for example, if you think about
BlackBerry, um, these are organizations
that kind of weren't in touch with what's going
on in the, in the space and as a result,
ended up, um, in a, in a space which
obviously deteriorated as a company.
Um, and so what our mission in life is to help
customers, obviously, we wanna
help the world run better, but certainly we wanna make sure
that our customers have longevity and they
do take advantages of, of what's going on in
the industry.
I love this quote by Peter Drucker. Anybody that's been
to a business school has read a book by Peter Drucker.
He's seen as the forefather of modern management.
The greatest danger in times of turbulence is not
the turbulence. It's the act of
yesterday's logic.
And quite often, when you're standing in
front of a customer and having a conversation with
them, you realize that people are dogmatic
to change and we all fear it.
And so as a result, one of the components of
conversation we're having with the customer today
is around adaptability. How does customers
adapt to what's going on in a world
that influences the
operating environment in which they, they're currently
doing business today.
I put this up as an interesting analogy, right? So
SAP still has an on-premise business. We
still sell software on-premise and we still have customers,
um, that we, uh, we manage
enhancements and upgrades with.
The light gray line in the middle is, in fact,
the enhancement release over a period of
time. So we release that to market.
That's the on-premise target adoption. And
the gray line underneath is when customers actually
spend the time adopting it,
which, by the way, has a gap of up to 7 years.
So when you think about a release that comes from us, which
is an enhancement of any shape, form, or size
within the software,
we give it to the customer.
And between the scheduling and programming that IT
goes through,
because of the constraints that they're under,
effectively, they only roll it out 7 years after
the fact.
All right. And uh that seems to be the
average norm.
Now, when you think about IT and business, there is
a wedge that seems to be growing between the two
organizations. Business is very much aware
of the, the hostile environment in which
they're operating in,
and IT still has the burden of compliance certification
and infrastructure management.
A large part of the customer base has lifted and shifted
some of that software and put it into a hyperscaler
like AWS for sure.
And for them in a subscription model,
we believe we're in the cloud.
The challenge is the agility. The challenge
is the compliance and certification
because IT still has to perform those functions.
So the programmatic approach that IT delivers
within an organization anywhere up to 12 months
in advance
is 25% around managed services and,
and contracts around managed services, finding the
right skill set,
deciding what gets upgraded to begin with.
And as business wants to pull away and make some
decisions around how do I modify my business
process, how do I go to market, take advantage
of new opportunities, etc.
IT has to push back and go, we've got all these
compliance things that we need to deal with. With
and so as a result, we can't deliver on that, right?
And there is definitely a wedge that's going on.
And what we see within the customer base
is we see
typically is that customers start building what
we call technical debt, OK.
So effectively, they go out to the business, uh, uh,
they go out to the world, business goes out to the world.
They've got some departmental budget, they go and buy
some software and they start implementing stuff themselves
and then try and figure out how the integration works.
And that's where you get the,
the technical debt starting to grow within the business.
There are challenges and when
A customer then starts need to think about how
do I upgrade, how do I move forward with innovations,
and that then speaks to the seven-year lag
in terms of the
innovation.
In a cloud-delivered world, in a, uh,
that compliance and certification and infrastructure
management
is delivered by SAP as a service. It's
a single throat to choke, and effectively what ends
up happening is we provide you managed services,
your infrastructure, we'll keep your software up and running,
and we'll make sure that all the enhancements are available
to you to consume. Whether it's in a private
or a public cloud environment.
What does that mean from IT? Because we release
you from the burden of compliance and
certification,
that means you can start focusing on innovation
for the business.
And our experience tells us that when we
spend time with a business, they tend to have
strategic objectives that they wanna drive,
but it's the operational objectives underneath
that, that they don't
explore to any great degree. Why?
Because IT can't support that deliverable.
So there's about 20% of availability
of time to focus on innovation, and it'll be
exploring the tires, kicking the tires around AI,
kicking the tires around innovation, making
sure that the integration is working, for example.
And when business wants to ideate around the future,
there's not enough time to do that
within the 20% of time available in the 12-month
period. So when you move that
to a cloud service, what typically happens is that
flips on its head.
You end up with 80% of your time availability. So
what does that mean? That means business and IT
can focus on what is the future of
the organization together and start
ideating on what does the future look like.
And that operational um strategic
intent gets delivered as a result.
OK. Uh, a little bit around some of the
technology trends that are going on in the industry, which have
nothing to do with SAP but it's worth mentioning.
This is something that customers need to consider
as you're moving forward to the cloud and as you're making
decisions around whether you're staying on-premise, whether you're
moving to the cloud. These are some of the strategic
thought processes.
If you think about the top left-hand side, uh,
supercomputing,
if I took all the data that
has ever been created in the whole of history and
put it into a single server in AWS,
we're gonna double the size of the data in 2 months.
OK. So that's as fast as
we are growing data in this world. Why?
Because of the mobile phone. Everybody takes 1520,
30 selfies,
uses one,
and basically never deletes anything, and everything else
goes into the cloud. OK. It's just in
human nature,
effect of us.
deleting anything.
I've been at SAP 16 years. I can go back
16 years and I can find the first email I
received from the CEO saying, Welcome to SAP.
Hope you have a great career with us.
And why didn't I delete it? Cause it's
just not in my nature to do so.
And human beings, unfortunately, don't do that.
So when we create data structures
within databases, we never delete them, recreate
them. If we create
analytical reports, we never delete them and recreate
them. As new people come on board, they simply push it
aside and go, I'll create this stuff again.
That's just human nature.
The second big trend that's going on is, um,
is in quantum computing.
It's a combination of mathematics, um, computer
science,
and the physical hardware itself.
What does that essentially mean? In layman's terms, it means
that some of the most complicated calculations
in humankind that we can think of, which
includes something like managing the human genome,
for example,
uh, would take conventional supercomputing
around 20,000 years to calculate. Quantum
computing tells us that we can do it under 5 minutes.
That changes the way that we operate or think
about operating a business,
particularly in things like life sciences, for example.
Also, when you think about artificial intelligence, we're
gonna have to think about new ways of saving data
because AI is used for nefarious intent
as much as I think it's gonna change the world.
It takes AI approximately 3.5
seconds to mimic your voice and it takes
about 5.5 seconds to mimic your face.
So picture this scenario.
There is a bank manager.
Who I don't know whether he's still currently employed
in Europe and uh
he got contacted by an artificial intelligence
and, and it was well crafted and created
to such a degree that he thought he was talking to his boss
and he ended up transferring $35 million
in his banking system without proper authorization
because his boss insisted that he did so.
And it was done through an artificial intelligence. Now you
can imagine. Um,
doing that in a private capacity where you'll have
your son phone you or daughter phone you going, hey,
mom, dad,
I apologize, but, uh, I left my wallet at home. I'm
driving. Can you give me my Social Security number?
And because I've got a credit card number and what have you, I
can buy a whole bunch of stuff on your behalf and it's,
it's more difficult to prove that you didn't purchase
it versus you did.
So AI is gonna be a challenge. Cybersecurity
is gonna be very, very important for us
to start locking down this data. So, cryptography
is gonna be a new way of looking at how
we're doing that, and that leads us to cybersecurity.
750,000 jobs available in the
US alone in cybersecurity right now.
OK. And the reason for that is because
Uh, it normally takes about 9 months to figure out that you've
had a data breach. You only get about 4 months,
or 4% of the data
back, 4 to 6%, somewhere around there.
And the reality is that that is gone. OK.
Uh, since I've joined, and moved to the
US, for example, I've had 4 breaches on my
credit card. So I've had to cancel a credit card and redo it.
And it's like,
hold on, how do people get my data?
Uh, because I registered my
My, uh, home at a home mortgage
company.
I registered my name on a telephone
line and I've registered in a postal
service and I bought a motorcar. And
those four
mean that my personal details are in the public domain
because it just gets sold by anybody in the business, right.
Um, and as a result, my details are out there.
So, interesting.
There is a convergence of the physical and virtual world.
Companies like uh Epic Games,
for example,
with these headsets have spent over $150
million creating virtual real estate.
Companies like Shopify have spent over $80
million trying to think about how it is that they're gonna
operate in an environment which is
virtual.
So, I don't know if any of you use YouTube
for any shape, form, or size, but the most frustrating
thing is I look at more adverts than I do actually
content in YouTube at the moment. Unless you purchase
a premium
kind of environment, right?
It give us new avenue for revenue streams.
So, absolutely, the headset is gonna be
quite an interesting development moving forward.
By 2026, apparently, one third of
the world's population is gonna spend 3.5 hours a
day on a headset.
That's a significant amount of people.
So it thinks about new, new avenues to
doing business, right?
The 5G network, well, because of the 5G
network, there's no latency of connectivity. I
can take a mobile device today. I can take a picture of
something immediately, it hits my transaction system.
I can consume it using AI and make decisions
around it. And the reality is there's no
latency of movement of data.
And the beauty of it is using AI
I can ask a question, get an answer, and tomorrow I come
back and do the same thing and get the same answer.
So the consistency of that is quite interesting
to see as well.
Artificial intelligence is self-explanatory, and
I'm absolutely certain you've been to a bunch of presentations
around it. But for me, what's quite
interesting at SAP is once I teach AI
to uh connect to a database
and another database together via APIs,
it can do it by itself.
If I'm sitting with an application sitting here
and data sitting in another application and I can
bridge it using
some code, as soon as I write the code, I
can teach AI to do the code.
And today, we have AI that actually writes
code.
All right. So I can bridge application to application, which
means I don't need to purchase or rebuild. I
can actually bridge it through an application layer.
And then finally, AI for me is around asking
a question and getting an answer.
So being able to sit there and ask a question within
the landscape in which you're operating,
whether it's SAP data or non-SAP data,
and being able to get that result back so that you can
drive an outcome within the business.
And being able to trust that
information. So all of these are influencing
how the world is operating. Also,
we've come to a new phenomenon around lifeline
lifelong learning.
So today,
uh, children that are entering primary school, by
the time they graduate and, and go to university,
26% of jobs that we know
today will be available. The rest are gonna be obsolete.
It doesn't mean there won't be jobs. It means that we're gonna have
different jobs.
So people need to ebb and flow through learning
culture and understanding how different
pieces of technology work, different functions
within a business work,
because you're not gonna be an accountant for 40 years.
You're gonna be looking at moving within the
organization and we have that within our company.
2.5 years on average, somebody looks
to get into another role within the business.
OK. Um, just in terms of when ERP
was first developed, I use this analogy cause I,
I find it quite interesting.
The left-hand side, we have a Jaguar Mark II, was
launched in 1955,
was stopped being made in 1975, but in
its day,
it was obviously an unbelievable machine.
It had a beautiful engine that could accelerate,
big 3 L motor,
4 L motor. It could do uh
unbelievable speeds.
It had a retractable seatbelt, which was one
of the first of its kind. So you could pull the seatbelt
down and you could release it and it would suck it
back up again.
The other thing, and the reason I know this is because my
father had one,
is the reality is I could push the a.m. FM
radio and the aerial would come out the bonnet
or come out the hood. Uh, we call it
a hood in the US.
And for me, that was great cause I used to turn it on and
off and watch this thing pop up and down. That
for me was the most advanced
technology available.
On the right-hand side, I've got an M4. Uh,
it's a BMW that was launched in the middle of last
year. You can see the capacity and the, and
the, and the comparison between the two vehicles in
terms of speed,
the size of the vehicle, the make of the model,
and all these good things.
The value of the technology that sits
inside the BMWs, is unbelievable. Electric
seats, electric windows,
heated seats, for example, onboard computers,
um, If I, uh,
for example, was going to a gala
event like this evening, for example, I'd take the jag.
Why? Because I'd wanna impress
the heck out of my wife.
And it'd arrive in style, right? James Bond
style in my mind.
Um, but the reality is if I was driving through
Europe, I was on the highway and I was going on a
vacation, I wanna be in the BMW.
Why? Because God forbid I have an accident.
Um, I've got the curtain airbags, and the
best possible chance of survival is
in the BMW.
The reality is,
why did I show you this? Because I cannot retrofit
the technology that sits in the BMW
back into the Jag. I could probably do a couple
of things like maybe put an onboard GPS system,
etc.
But I can't put the airbags in it and I can't
retrofit the suspension and the capabilities
of, of the actual vehicle itself, uh, OK,
without losing its value.
The point is that
this analogy I see very often happening with
customers.
Instead of looking at modernizing the technology,
we tend to look at pieces of
technology that can add value and we create more and
more technical debt
within the landscape in which we operate.
That doesn't bode well when we start thinking about agility
within the organization,
right? So just to give you something for a little
bit of tongue in cheek.
When we launched ERP ECC6, we
built it in the 90s.
It was launched in the early 2000s, but in those
days, um, there was no smartphone.
Smartphone was just released, so telephone, mobile
phone was just released.
There was no internet. There was no Amazon, there was
no Google. There were no blogs.
There was no social networks. There was no e-commerce.
There were no millennials.
There were certainly no app stores. There were no selfies,
no FOMO,
fear of missing out, for example.
No Wikipedia, no streaming, no cloud,
no AI,
no APIs, and no in-memory
computing.
And we still have lots of customers operating in this
world today.
OK. Uh, in the backdrop of
a world that is accelerating
change,
and let's face it, our customers are driving that
behavior. Uh, to give you an example, I've
got 5 or 6 apps that we'll call a
taxi in the US.
My first primary goal is to pull an Uber.
Why? Because it's integrated into my,
my, uh, uh, uh, costing
system.
Uh, if, for example,
uh, I can't, uh, it tells me I get
2 minutes for the driver to arrive, yup, OK,
commit.
And then it finds me in driver and comes back 17 minutes
later, I hit the cancel button just for the heck
of it. Because why? I'm not loyal to
Uber. It's just you promised me something, you didn't
deliver it, so I'm going somewhere else.
And that's exactly what we have with Amazon and a whole
bunch of
capabilities today. We are finicky consumers
and that's why companies need to be a little bit more agile.
So a little around the business suite, um,
At the core of our strategy is AI,
OK. And we believe that AI has fundamentally
changed the world
and will continue to change the world as we move
forward. And yes, you probably find
from every single vendor that's out there talking about
AI saying, yeah, AI, AI, AI, and
that's great. AI on its own
is not gonna provide the value. Why? Because
it needs to have real data to operate
off. If you don't have real data
and rich data and qualified data, etc.
it actually doesn't operate really well.
Now, at SAP we have an
application layer that you've trusted for 53 years,
an ERP layer that generates that
trusted data.
And getting access to that trusted data, we
think that's the flywheel effect. So effectively, AI
will read the data, give you some insights, you'll make
some decisions, possibly change the way that the
business operates, possibly change the way that
the application is operating.
And as a result, that'll generate new data. That
new data is consumed through AI and continually,
that's how you find the flywheel effect in, in place.
So, for us at SAP it's all about
uh the application layer, the data,
and AI.
And if you look in the industry today, there is nobody
out there that provides all three capabilities,
OK? You will have vendors that'll provide
you certainly an application layer.
Certainly, they'll look into the data, and certainly
they'll look into AI,
but not all three things together. This is where
we see the real value.
OK. Just a little around um
the suite. So this introduces the suite.
It's the new uh um Pia
diagram that you'll see on your left-hand side.
At the core of which is uh obviously the
SAP
cloud ERP.
Underneath that is something called the Business Data Cloud.
And we'll touch on that, uh, fairly shortly.
Underneath that, you have the business technology platform.
Sitting on top of the ERP layer is
obviously the lines of business solutions
with industry-specific capability that
gets delivered with it.
On top of that is the artificial intelligence, which
is already embedded.
And then the natural language interface is called DL.
All right, which is basically how it's
the new UI for SAP.
So as much as you could be on ECC6 with a
GUUI front end, you could also be on S4
HANA, which has got a Fiori front end.
But the capability that sits in cloud is is
that your new UI and your starting point
to engage with a piece of software will actually be
through something called JL,
which is your natural language interface.
So yes, Juul runs across human resources, sales,
procurement, IT sourcing,
etc. Pretty much procurement everywhere
inside of cloud ERP.
All right. Just a little around the AI strategy.
Um, well, you probably have seen this slide
before, but effectively,
everything starts and runs with AI, uh, in a
dual interface.
So as you talk to it, it's a natural language interface.
So effectively, you would simply type in your natural
language query,
and it would actually direct you to where your query
is operating.
We have also developed some AI capability
which has been embedded in both the lines of
business as well as into the cloud ERP, private
cloud as well as public cloud.
And the point is, that when you put a modernized ERP
platform in place, it takes time to actually activate.
So effectively,
it is a separate project, but you can activate the
embedded AI capability.
Jules takes about 2 to 3 hours to activate
in some of the ERP layer.
Um, you would simply decide on the use cases. There
are 400 of them available to you at the moment
in various lines of business as well as in the cloud
ERP. You simply activate those.
We have something called the AI Foundation underneath
that. That's part of the BTP stack
Business Technology Platform.
And effectively, what that'll allow you to do is it'll
allow you to engage with third-party solutions.
We are not a large language model provider.
You can use any one of the external large language
providers if that's your choice.
You would simply integrate it using Juul.
You would simply integrate it using the AI Foundation.
So, we have an open standards platform, not
really interested in understanding. Um,
how to rewrite large language models. That's
not the game we're in.
I thought this would be quite interesting.
We released our Q3 results.
And unfortunately, the, uh,
the sound's not coming through, but anyway,
you can see it's just natural language, asking some
questions. Juul responds accordingly
and gives you some answers.
I thought this was a really neat way of how we
actually went to market with our,
our Q3 results. It's pretty much how
we launched it. It gives you a flavor of
how you would interact with the software itself and I'm not
gonna Uh, so
just moving on as far as the dual patterns
are concerned, I'll just build this out quickly.
Basically, it's informational, right? So how do
I find something within the system? Uh, so
for example, if I'm looking for credit notes.
Normally in a GUI front end, you would have to know where
the screen is. You would have to navigate through the menu
system to get to where it is that you need
to operate. Within Juul, you're simply asking
a question and getting an answer.
That's the navigational one. That's the second one. The first
one is around,
for example, if I'm taking customers out
to dinner, I have some compliance issues I
need to deal with. So am I doing a deal with a customer? Is
it a public sector customer?
How much money can I spend,
right? At the end of the day, in,
in the past, I would have to get a hold of, uh, I
would have to create a ticket, send it off to HR going,
I'm taking some customers out. This is the circumstance.
This is what's going on. Can you tell me how much am I allowed
to spend? Once I get that information, I
send it on to my manager saying, is it part of the budget? Can
I spend it? Yes or no?
Manager says yes. If for some
unknown reason I go over that spend at nighttime,
I have to pay for the difference. OK. So I wanna be
careful about how I do that. Inside
Juulel today, I can take my mobile phone
going, I'm going out to dinner.
I'm spending, there's 10 people. I'm
in Orlando. I'm in, uh,
Las Vegas and I'm going out to dinner with a customer.
Uh, how much money can I spend? And it'll come back and tell
me straight away.
And if I want to, it'll ask me, it'll say, do you want your
manager's approval? Yes. And it'll auto reroute
to the cust uh to the manager
who has to reroute. That saves me weeks
of of time, right?
We've explained the, uh, navigational transactional
is, uh, for example, I see some,
uh, some credit notes coming through,
uh, from a customer or an angry email.
OK. So it's gonna say, uh, simple things
like Uh, uh, you,
uh, promised me a delivery. I ordered some stuff. I've
paid for it. You've sent me an invoice for it, but only half
was delivered. What's going on?
Now, in a normal set of circumstances, I would have to
engage with a credit control clerk. I would have to
engage with the sales guy. I'd have to engage with the delivery
person, etc. right throughout the, the
supply chain of selling, well, the supply chain of
delivery. And what will happen with transactional
capabilities is Jewel will actually navigate to all
of those things, pull them all up for you so you can make an
informed decision.
And then we'll ask you, do you want me to write the email to apologize
to the customer,
or do you wanna send the customer the next order, or what's
the response that you, so it'll actually give you
the conclusion of the, the transaction. Saves
you a significant amount of time.
And then analytically, I think this is probably
one of the most advanced capabilities that exist
within the suite
is about being able to ask a question
and get an answer.
Typically, we spend a lot of time
capturing information into a transaction system.
And then trying to extrapolate that, contextualize
it, and put it into the hands of decision makers
so that they can make decisions effectively as possible.
So, we are people that create thousands
of reports and send it to hundreds of people within
the business, etc. And again,
we don't manage that landscape. On an AI
landscape, what, what is interesting.
As you can simply ask a question. It'll execute
the response,
give you an understanding, and you can make a decision
on it. You can even forward it and collaborate
with other individuals
on the same decision point so that you can deliver on
it. Cause tomorrow, I can ask the same
question and I can get the same answer.
So again, improving the way that you operate within the
business. So we believe that you will save as much
as 30% operational
value by utilizing something like Juulel within
the suite
at SAP.
OK. Uh, AI agents, and I
know you've probably been to some presentations
on Agentic AI,
but that for us is the next layer up. So effectively,
we've created
AI agents already sitting
inside of the lines of business.
But for us at SAP it's simple enough to say
that, look,
you know, we recognize that
Uh, decisions that are made within the
organization run across the business. It
runs across finance, runs across supply chain,
runs across procurement, runs across all these
decision makers.
And as opposed to getting decisions out of each
of those individuals,
you can have an AI agentic AI coordinating
with AI agents that already exist.
So you can have something that orchestrates it all,
OK. And that's the next layer up from
an SAP point of view.
So there are plenty of dual agents available. We've got
a whole bunch that were recently released
as part of the uh the embedded AI capability.
There's a significant amount of them that are available.
You simply have capability to look at
a catalog
and then determine what is available uh
from the catalog.
Inside of the, the suite of solutions as
well, you will also get access to something called dual
Studio.
Because we believe at SAP we're not all things to all
men. We'll continue to build embedded
AI capabilities for sure that you
can consume as a customer,
but we won't build everything for all industries and
for all value sets, right, and for all lines of
business. So you get something called Duual
Studio which gives you access. It's part of the
BTP stack.
Again, effectively using SAP
Build, you can go and build your own
natural language queries, OK, within
your system.
So especially if you've customized your system a
little bit, etc.
that you take on your own nuances within the business.
So you have the ability to then build your
own natural language interface, uh, and queries.
And I mentioned a little earlier, you get the
opportunity to discover, manage, and govern
all of the agents in one place. Whether it was
SAP created,
whether you created it, or whether it was custom-created
by a non uh SAP customer,
or excuse me, from a partner's point of view. So,
literally, you get the ability to look into,
I'm looking for financial embedded AI
capabilities. What does that look like?
And it'll show you the availability that is applicable,
yes or no. And you can then choose to deploy it
or not. So
certainly, um, uh, something
else that
exists within, uh, some of the agent mining
in a, in a solution set called Signalvia,
um, it'll, it'll, um,
Juul will help you not only trace agent decision and
action. So in other words,
what are the agents that are deployed,
what needs to be, uh, managed and governed, um,
but also start looking at some of your
business processes and flagging where some
of those bottlenecks are, uh, within the solution
area. And then basically monitoring it
and coming up with recommendations on how to optimize
it. So this is AI that's embedded
in the actual business process management
technology called Signalvia.
And what we've done at SAP is we not only
talk about how customers are consuming it, we're actually
embedding it in our own lifestyle, our
own application, our own, uh, internally
at SAP. So we're consuming our own software.
So we talked about AI. We're gonna
talk a little bit about the data, uh, piece
and SAP at the beginning of last
year, um, had to make a decision
around, uh, the data because what
we were noticing is that a large part of the customers
were moving into the data and extract
extrapolating the data into third-party solutions,
trying to build contextualization on the data
and putting analytical solutions and yes, in
some, in some cases, even um AI
capabilities on the front end
and trying to deliver that to, to the businesses,
as providing.
And so we made a decision to fundamentally change
the SAP strategy, which was we built the contextualization
for you. We launched a product called Business
Data Cloud, and effectively, that creates
a semantic layer that sits on top of
SAP.
So if you're looking to run a query or you're looking to
understand anything in terms of either line of
business or at the ERP layer, you
work through BDC.
And BDC is a zero copy capability.
So effectively,
on the front end, we've built, uh, on the back end, we've built
the data products for you.
There's 200 data products that have been pre-built.
So, in other words, the source to target mapping has
already been done for you. And you simply embed
the um uh the data product.
And effectively, what you would do is when you run the query
on the front end,
whether it's an analytical query, whether it's
a whether it's an AI query,
etc. it basically understands where the
data resides.
Not only that, we have a relationship with, um,
with a company called Data Bricks.
Um, which essentially,
um,
allows us to actually access third-party data
or non-SAP data.
So effectively, what you have now is this capability
in, in BDC to say, well, I'm looking
for, uh, you know, if the customer's using
an HR tool that's outside of SAP, for
example, I'm looking for my cost
comparison by employee, for example.
I'm gonna be pulling from my financial system, which
is gonna come through BDC.
And I'm gonna be pulling from uh
uh an external third-party HR product
or solution utilizing uh data
bricks. And I can get a viewpoint on
what's going on within the business. Again, AI
is applied on the top of that.
And so what we've also then decided to do is
build what we call,
um, uh, intelligent
applications. So we're creating an HR
application. We're creating a finance application. We're creating,
uh, a procurement application which basically
fundamentally aggregates all the data for you.
Again, we're not copying the data into
a third-party solution.
So in an AWS environment, for example,
when you're sitting in a hyperscale, we're not lifting and shifting
the transaction data
and replicating it in an enterprise data warehouse.
What BDC also does is it gives you access
to your data warehouse already BW that's
already deployed. So I know 2033
is when BW comes to an end from a support point
of view. What this does is it sees BW
as another data source
and will aggregate or do zero copy data
as you need it. So if you've got all your SLTs
which have been programmed into a BW environment, you
can continue to use it and extend the lifespan
of the work that's already been done.
All right. And a little around the customer journey.
So some customers are sitting on-premise,
ECC6. Some customers are sitting with
a, a certified uh S4
implementation uh on-premise.
Some customers have taken that implementation
and gone to a hyperscale as well.
Um, at the end of the day, uh, it doesn't matter
where your journey begins. Um,
one thing that SAP is synonymous
with is at the beginning of each year,
we change the naming conventions for some of the
products and solutions.
Apologies for that, but that's just the way it is.
Um, as it is today, uh, the business
suite is a marketing terminology.
And really what you need to understand is the journey that
you're gonna follow. All right. So effectively,
there are two journeys. There's one called Rise and one
called Grow.
The Rise journey is for existing customers
on-premise that are moving to the cloud.
All right. And the grow environment is a green field
implementation that typically is a customer who is
a non-SAP customer.
And we have a lot of those net new customers that come on
board every year.
It doesn't matter what your ERP layer is, it's a
simple green field implementation.
And the migration path for a Ryse
customer is either brownfield,
um, or a brownfield and a green field combination.
Um, and it could be an on-premise, excuse
me, it could be a private cloud
or a public cloud environment. We have some hybrid
customers out there that have a,
for example, a private cloud environment for the head
office and some of the satellite,
um, environments that they're operating in. So, for
example, some of the mining companies, they got some public cloud
deployments,
all right, that have been deployed. So we do get that hybrid
environment as well.
But in essence, for a Greenfield customer,
uh, the starting point is,
obviously, you have any ERP that's in
place, Greenfield ERP transformation
into the suite.
And then, uh, for a private cloud customer,
typically, you have ECC6
with some of the legacy modules that sit around
it. And in order to get to the suite,
typically, the first step would be, well, we lift
and shift into a modernized ERP platform, which
is S4 HANA.
The second piece of it is we, uh, we then
move obviously the legacy modules
into the private cloud environment
so that you have a, a managed service environment
that gets delivered. So SAP becomes that
single throat to choke for a customer who's
looking for
compliance and certification around all of the ERP
layer, including the lines of business.
The next layer up is, is that you would look at
taking some of those legacy modules and putting
them onto a public cloud environment. So for
example, BW would get into BDP
APO would be getting into IBP.
Concur and HCM into success
factors.
OK, so that you end up with a combination of private
and public cloud.
And ultimately, at the end of the day, we look at it from
a suite point of view. Your target end state
could be everything in public cloud.
It could be someone in private cloud and a combination
of both.
But ultimately, that's the journey that you would follow.
OK. And then
of course
every journey that every customer is on.
Um, is a difficult one. All right.
And so,
as a result, it's complex. And
so what we've done at SAP
is we provide a framework,
an integrated tool chain, plus the skill
set to help you understand how you get there.
OK. So we will actually map the roadmap for
you. And that's broken down into obviously
those three areas, which I will move on.
The third, uh, uh, the framework itself is
literally um a
uh
A a SAP methodology that gets
delivered at every single um gate
that you understand
from the engagement to the delivery of the solution
area, you would understand the roles and responsibilities
of SAP,
the roles and responsibility of you as the customer,
as well as your partners. You get something called
the cloud adoption framework, which gets
delivered
where basically you get to understand the visible
uh steps to actually move to cloud.
The second piece of it is you will get an integrated tool
chain. OK. And the integrated tool chain is
part of the
procurement process that you would go through with SAP.
But effectively, there's an integrated
technology which helps you with your transformation. And I'll,
I'll explain that shortly.
And then finally, you get expert guidance, right?
Not only from SAP
but we have a bunch of partners out there that have gone through certified
training. I
wanna touch on the Clean Core a little bit, um,
because it is an important part of the journey that you're on,
right? So what is Clean Core? It's essentially,
most customers, what they've done is take an ERP,
uh, in ECC6, for example, and they've
customized it to the Yin-Yang.
So they've looked at the business process.
The original implementation went, go to an SI,
look at the business process I have,
look at what's standard with SAP and modify it
as much as you can, OK, in order to suit the business
process. So what you end up with is customers
in some customer cases, up to half a million
Z code changes within an application
layer. Now, to move that into a cloud
environment, and that also hinders things like upgrades,
etc. to move that into a cloud environment
is a real challenge. OK. So, how
do you deal with it?
Uh, the idea is, is that you wanna get it as
standard as possible
and decide what is nuanced for the business
that you need.
So typically, you, you, you, uh, in a brownfield
implementation, you would look at it and say, how do I
get the core clean?
All right. And the second piece of it is how do I keep it
clean. All right.
And you have two options, um, in a,
in a, in a green field implementation which is
grow, you simply have to keep the core clean,
uh, essentially.
But you have two options. You either create custom
code. And you build it in a public cloud
server called BTP which sits next to
your private cloud environment.
So all your functional calls, etc. happen on
the public cloud server, which is fine, no
issue. If there's a communication protocol
issue between the two servers, you can actually build
it on stack. So we have it off-stack as well as
on-Stack.
Off-Stack being on a BTP environment.
And typically, those things are turned around in a few weeks.
So it's not difficult to do.
Um, so essentially part of the, the
Clean core methodology is looking at
it going, what, what needs to be modified, what
needs to be made S4 ready? What are
some of the code that we can get rid of? Cause up to 40%
of the code that's being deployed, cause nobody
deletes anything,
you can simply toss because you're not using, right?
And we would help you through that process.
And certainly there's some white papers out there which show
customers, listen, this is how you would approach
uh uh a cleaner core environment.
Some customers do it upfront. So before they
move through the transformation
to S4, some customers do it post the facts, so
they do a
green field implementation and then they start moving data
across and start figuring it out from that point
of view. It makes it more difficult,
certainly, but certainly palatable. Um, so
either or,
uh, whichever works for you as a customer.
Uh, now we move into the, the tool chain
itself, um,
the integrated tool chain. And with that,
uh, some of the integrated tool chain that you will get
access to is, uh, a business
process mining solution,
uh, which deals with processes,
applications, and people.
Um, so it binds those three concepts together.
Um, so for example, in the process engine, you
have Signnavia,
which is a business process management engine. It'll
tell you what is best in class in terms of the business
process, trying to keep it as standard as possible.
It'll then go down into your, uh, business
processes that you're already using. So it'll look
through an insights engine. It'll show you where the
gaps are in the business process. It'll
map it back to the standards.
You have a collaboration engine which allows you to
collaborate with everybody in the business process and
you can sit there and go, well, tell me what it is you'd
like to see.
And then you can build it inside of a framework and
you can test and run some data against it and if
you like it, you can deploy it.
All right. On the
application side,
Lean IX is the enterprise architecture tool. So
that basically allows you to document
all of the software applications that you're running, all
the managed services environments that you're up and running,
all the network connectivity and protocols that you're
running, and it's fully integrated into Signnavia.
So when you make a business process change, for example,
you would immediately see what is impacted within
the enterprise architecture layer within the
business. All right. Why is that important?
Cause we spoke about it at the, at the beginning
where there's this wedge developing between business
and IT
because now what happens is business says, oh, I wanna do this
merger and acquisition. I wanna go ahead and do this. I
wanna buy this. I wanna send this new product to market, etc.
You now have the capability as IT to look into
it and go,
Mr. CFO, you know that, uh,
solution you were asking for. We have to
downscale this, we have to purchase that. We have to do
all these, um, upscale the servers,
environments, etc. etc.
It's gonna cost 5 months' worth of, uh, management
time and about $50 million. Do you wanna do it? Yes
or no? And then there's an informed
decision. But again, it's a collaboration that
happens between business and IT and we say it's
the handshake between the two.
Then you look at the people, right?
So when, as and when you get into
innovation, typically what ends up happening is when you
roll out a new innovation, we train everybody.
Everybody's thumbs up. I'm good with the
training. I go home, I have a great night, I
come back tomorrow and I look at the screen and I go,
what happened and where was I and what am I doing?
And so there's this uh tool set. Part of the
integrated tool chain is a product called WalkM,
which basically will show you through a workflow
application saying this is where you were before, this is how you
process, this is where you are now, and this is how you need to
move forward.
So it stops me having to raise a ticket. Please
get somebody out here so I can get some more
training. Um, and so I get a better
understanding of what's going on. Similarly,
from a management point of view, you have a dashboard that
tells you how many people within the business process
that you've just rolled out are consuming and
using the new business process.
So if there there's nobody using it, your business
is not adopting the change, we can then go back
into the, the team and nominate people
and go, what's the issue? How do we
fix it? All right. And part of that
integrated tool chain is something called automated testing.
So every single enhancement
that you get delivered either from SAP or you
build yourself, you're gonna have to run through a testing protocol
and management.
And the way to do that, um, in
today's world is to do it through an automation,
which basically gives you, uh, where's the risk,
risky code, where's the problematic
data that I'm gonna be accessing.
Etc. So that that's what you focus on.
It'll save you up to about 90% of the time
that's, that's in uh in testing
environment. What does that mean? That means I can
deliver enhancements faster to the business
on a more rapid pace.
All right. And then underlying uh
the business data cloud, uh under there is the business
technology platform.
And that's part of the integrated tool chain, right? And
you will get access to it.
Effectively, the business technology platform is an
aggregate bunch of technologies, of
course. The first and primary piece
of that is the integration suite, which sits in the middle.
And so when you're moving to cloud, you're gonna have to integrate
cloud to on-premise, cloud to cloud applications, etc.
right? So that's not gonna change.
And typically you would need to have a framework that
allows you to basically manage that environment as
you move forward. On the left-hand side,
application development and automation. So if you're building
something, you're extending something, building
extensibility within the business itself,
or you're building AI or dual capability,
you're gonna build it
inside of BTP. This is where it's housed.
You have the capability to run full ABA
code, so professional code, you can have limited
code or you can have no code development, all sitting
within BTP.
So if you choose to have no code development,
it's simply dragging and dropping and running
specific simple applications
on mobile devices, for example, and then we get a variance
in between.
All right. And on the right-hand side, we talk about data and analysis.
Data means how do I manage my data in the cloud.
So it's the database, the integration framework,
um, that sits with it.
And then certainly the analytical tools. So analytics
cloud, for example,
and then underneath that is the artificial intelligence
that all sits
within the BTP stack. OK.
And so as a result, customers, as
they purchase,
would, would consume that.
And in summary, I think this will be
how we bring it all together.
So, to me, there is, and to SAP
there is a transformation program to
go through and an innovation program.
And what we often talk to our customer about is
we talk to them about perpetual innovation in
a world in a backdrop that we painted at the outset,
which is this world that we're operating in,
which is exposing us to consistent change.
How do I go through that? So a customer that's sitting
on-premise.
Um, or an on-premise solution.
Let's assume that they need to move through to cloud,
cloud ERP.
Well, absolutely, they'll move through cloud ERP. The
first part of which is I'll need
to fix my data.
I'll need to look at the data,
what's managed, what's governed, what's clean, what's unmanaged,
uh, what's deduplicated, what needs to be, uh,
what's missing in terms of the data. Data integrity.
Is the fundamental science or fundamental basis
of how you're gonna consume
information within the business, right? So, and
we spend a lot of time, effort, and money taking
information out of the transaction system,
loading it into a warehouse, and then putting analytical
tools on the front end for that information.
But you have to deal with the data. Is it S4
ready? Is it in memory, capable,
um, etc. right? So, yes, you
have to have a, a data quality management
program in place
because that then becomes the fundamental basis of how
you run artificial intelligence within your
organization. The second piece is around
the cleaner core approach. We spoke a little bit about
that. How do I get rid of the code that's
there? Um, because the idea is
in the past when you bought an on-premise piece
of software, as I mentioned, you would customize
the yin-yang out of it
to suit the business process. That's been turned on its
head. Today, we want you to run as
standard as possible and the nuances
of your organization, you would build inside a BTP
through the SAP build environment,
OK? Or you build it external
outside of the core. And the idea is, is that you can
then upgrade your systems and keep upgraded
as new, uh, enhancements are released.
To give you an example, we have a customer who
can upgrade their system and did so.
They switched off their system at 6 o'clock on a
Friday night and they were back up 14 minutes later.
All right, because they had a clean core environment.
And I'd love to see some customers. Some customers take
5 months to upgrade. Some customers just don't bother.
OK. Because it's too uh uh to,
to unpack that uh uh is a real
issue. So how do you get a, a
cleaner core?
And then, um, as you do that, you would
then roll out BTP
underneath, um, uh, the solution
area which deals with integration and data management
to begin with.
And at a later stage, we'll deal with s,
planning, obviously, financial planning and forecasting,
and then the business data cloud, which is then
part of the BTP stack as well.
We talked about the integrated tool chain, so the business
process management engine
and the enterprise architecture. You would roll out Signnavia,
you would roll out LeanIX.
You would roll out WalkMe, and then the
development or the uh testing tool is Tricentis,
which is a third-bo tool,
but nevertheless, one that we love using, um,
because it integrates directly into Calm.
Uh, with that, you will also get capabilities
to run AI application accelerators, some
that are built in Signnavia that we discussed,
and some that are built inside of BTP as well.
So the idea is to help you
transform as fast as possible, um,
within boundaries, of course.
And with that, you would get the methodology that
goes with it. So that's the cloud adoption framework
as well as the SAP
methodology. And I, I mentioned earlier that
the cloud adoption framework
spells out the roles and responsibility
of you, the partner, or partners,
as well as SAP in every stage of the implementation.
And then finally, that sits on top of um
SAP application life cycle Manager.
And for those of you that don't know,
uh calm as I call it, just keep calm.
Cloud application life cycle manager
effectively is um pretty much
what IT would use to
figure out where there are challenges within the
existing um framework of the business. So
for example,
is there a problem with one of the processes? Is there a
problem with one of the, the data sets not integrating
properly? Is there a problem with some of the integration,
for example,
um, and basically would show you where those problems
are so that IT can then focus on,
on where that challenge is.
Once you've got to this point, a modernized ERP
platform, you can activate JO.
Uh, JOL's capable, um, inside of
I think, uh, uh, modernized ERP
platform for sure.
Um,
both at the ERP layer as well as the lines of
business as you move on.
But then we start talking about innovation, right? So
how does the business innovate?
Well, how do we create extensibility? How
do we create automation?
How do we figure out on changes to the business
process, for example,
how do we automate testing? How do we, uh,
deliver something like business data cloud into the
organization, delivering artificial intelligence.
And I use this kind of analogy here
that never ends, right? Innovation never
ends. We're in a world where innovation
has to be perpetual in order to provide
value because the position keeps changing.
And as an organization, unless you have a captive
audience that has no choice but to buy your solutions,
the fact of the matter is we obviously
need to still keep growing our businesses and we
have to do more with less.
And the only way to continually doing that is to
make sure that you utilize the solution areas, right?
So the integrated tool chain will remain
within the business and gets continued to be
used. AI
on the business process engine will show you where
there are still further bottlenecks that start
developing within the business. And over time, you
get that capability to drive.
All right. And then finally, you start talking about things like
artificial intelligence, the rollout of DL,
augmented analytics, for example,
how do you automate things and how do you build extensions
on inside of BTP.
Now, any organization that's going through a, a
modern ERP
deployment, you can lift and shift, move to an on-premise
world, and then from an on-premise single instance
S forward uh harness system,
then move into a, a cloud application,
look at a hyperscalar, etc. The
journey is endless.
From an SAP point of view, we would help you define
what that looks like.
So we would spend time with your organization, first
figuring out where your innovation strategy is
and what your culture within your business is.
The second piece about it is, is trying to figure
out what your end state looks like. So what is your,
what's your operating model now and versus
what the operating model is in the cloud
as it is. The third piece of it is how
we give you something called platform assurance.
Because when you take your infrastructure and you give it to SAP,
you wanna know that it's 99.7% to 99.999%
uptime.
That there's no challenges with that. We manage 150,000
SAP systems around the world
using the hyperscales to do it. OK. So
we have
a huge infrastructure managed, um,
managed services environment within the SAP.
So we'll look at those three things
and then we will look at innovation within your business
and we will then define what your end-state target
needs to look like across the journeys
that we discussed.
So what does your end-state look like? Where, what is your first
step in the journey? What does that look like, etc.
That will then facilitate the business case,
which then would go off to the organization
and then we would help you deliver on that.
And that would be the journey from SAP.
Do we have any questions?
Well, thank you very much. I hope that uh you enjoyed
the session and please enjoy the rest of the day. Thank
you.